il
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette
troisième ville et au japon on est à
tokyo et plus précisément à kabala joue
ses cartes geek on avait visité un
sex-shop maxime rien il ya trop de trous
dans cette chose on va pas commencer par
le sex-shop mais pour aller dans une
petite salle arcade law and justice issa
d'homère desquels bon youtuber oh là là
et tu es excité les atouts dans cet
endroit plutôt rythme plutôt un bon avec
mon père me s'affronter sur tekken le
jeu de notre enfance
tmg prix bas mais larry brian je me suis
heureusement on sent qu est ce que tu
déplore ce qui compte c'est que tu
perdes
oh
oh c'est le chat salut qu'à auch à l'ess
qui veut latéralement mène 2-1 hier au
monde
il fait 0 shop
il composait ont chanté et yann c'est
honteux
ça fait du bien la belle salaire de
lamelles
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gachet
tu termines sortir du bâtiment on a joué
pendant une heure et problème c'est que
dans les salles arcade est en droit de
fumer à l'intérieur les japonais et du
coup ça la clope quand tu sors de là tu
pues de ouf
tu peux nous fait les amis je suis
extrêmement content vient de rentrer
dans un magasin figurines et je suis
tombé sur quoi sur le ironman samouraï
il est absolument incroyable mon frère a
craqué au top me regarder les lieux et
tu nous fais l'amour mais c'est pas tout
car j'ai aussi pris le spy domaine aucun
cas par an peut trouver tout ce qui est
en rapport avec la culture geek y
compris des cartes y en a un paquet à
l'écart des dizaines qu'elles sont trop
belles elle brille tout géant succès des
cartes légendaire jeu mario saviez mais
à certaines cartes de certains jeux qui
peuvent coûter jusqu'à 1000 euros selon
leur rareté voire plus complètement
dingue les amis je suis à nouveau une
salle un câble et je viens de trouver
sur la figurine la plus perverse et la
plus cool de tous les temps devait donc
investir on l'a remporté et la mettre
mon décor
[Musique]
bon petit bilan de la situation au cas
où vous ne le saviez pas ces machines en
fait sont régler manuellement tous les
jours à des heures différentes ya un
bouton qui règle la porte de la prise de
la panse un bouton qui règle la force
d'appui etc bref la machine sur laquelle
on est tombé j'ai pas eu de chance elle
était fait pour que tu perdes tellement
ça qu'il faut toujours regarder un mail
jouer avant soit pour voir si la poste a
grippe ou pas et ça change sur les jours
et les heures et les machines ce
terrible et je me suis obstinée pour une
fille et aux gros seins comme beaucoup
de gens tous les jours en france je
n'aurais jamais dû je regrette tellement
c'est une défaite totale pour les
cadeaux cher aujourd'hui après je vais
pas vous mentir je sais quoi faire pour
me consoler c'est bon ça va mieux je me
sens dans mon élément
je suis très excité je pense fort à toi
cyprien ouais d'accord pour les amish
sortie de ce magasin malsain j'ai acheté
un petit cadeau qu'on va offrir ce soir
à quelqu'un je ne vous dis pas ce que
c'est je ne vous dis pas non plus le nom
de la personne qui je vais l'offrir doit
être très drôle et surtout très très
très gênant mais on va aller au plus
gros magasin de figurines de l'endroit
et on va savoir si après tout le boulot
saviez vous que tom cruise n'avait pas
18 mois ce qui se passait et bergot que
tu peux acheter ici des corps nus de
figurines et ensuite tu achètes les
têtes de tes stars préférées
bonjour je suis jackie chan mais en fin
de carrière florent je crois que emile
et ça ça me fiche un corps de femme
personne ne veut voir sa faune sa salle
aux cordes c'est la tête et ça c'est là
que du fatah tateurs super glauque
attention jouve le corps crois qu'on est
en train de créer la plus belle figurine
du monde
oh [ __ ] quand alors je peux pas vous
montrer pour le moment faut que je sens
furent amenés maigret et textures mais
nous tous il trop loin ça te jure elle
pue du cul ce que c'est pas un
photographe de force
par contre je crois que quelqu'un en
fait ces 18 pays envers côté pervers en
fait on fait comme les l'offre soirée on
remonte un peu le décolleté au [ __ ]
ok le devant alors j'ai attention le
derrière un petit à petit ce qu'on fait
à jacques bichot attentionné en finale
franchement ça l'fait alors maintenant
j'aimerais faire un petit chef jim de
lagardelle
on dirait qu'il est vrai nom ne le peux
pas me regarder comme ça ça me dérange
jacky qu'est ce qui te revient envie de
me faire des câlins à salut c'est jackie
chan n'hésite pas à ta bonne et il est
maintenant temps de rejoindre de copains
youtuber dont l'un qui va recevoir un
beau cadeau à l'opus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en vrai il est beau il s'appelle
losemann germain dans la vraie vie
attention ici on à qui on agit d on
vient de manger tu espères merde j'ai un
petit cadeau pour jb déjà conforme à la
loi
je pense savoir ce que c'est
attention l'accord qui peuvent accord
c'est une main qui va pas me servir à
à quelques plaisirs et l'actrice
pornographique japonaise ils ont
modélisé son corps et c'est une
reproduction parfaite de son brave
notamment percival ouvrir je pense que
c'est le parfait moment on n'est pas un
restaurant c'est l'endroit idéal s'était
passé le réflexe mondial toni la leçon
harry potter ou je te détruit le mois
passé voir harry potter façon bizarre
ab j lo païs bras mais c'est quoi ce
délire il est tout petit j'ai pas
toujours prises mais pourquoi il est mou
comme ça ne s'est pas encore les ja je
la quitte et ce but il faut le guen
taccetti jours mais c'est un bras
fracturé ouverte en fait il ya un
fantasme et si la facture au vert merci
beaucoup lui j'adore mais ça répond
faire pardonner de ta défaite sur les
résultats oui bah ouais super et bien
les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo
merci germain alias neumann
merci j'ai pas de cadeau j bay qui joue
avec son nouveau jouet là j'aime
beaucoup
n'oubliez pas le pouce en l'air à les
revoir
[Musique]
au lac étale aujourd'hui on va aller à
harajuku 1 du coup c'est un endroit il
ya plein de petites boutiques cool mais
ça on s'en fout ce que je vais faire
surtout c'est allé chez le coiffeur
parce que là ça devient critique de
malade et je me suis dit ça peut être
drôle d'ailleurs dans un port japonais
de le dire écoute c'est moi ce que tu
veux elle c'est parti bon je suis
harajuku devant un salon de coiffure
très très beaux arts un ca de la place
bon le salon est plein on est hyper déçu
cia puisse y avait marqué des prix genre
meilleur salon d'europe même si japon
sport en europe ce paradis je suis dans
un salon et ça va peut-être passer
serait bien que ça se passe ici le salon
est cool du coup je pense pas je me
retrouve avec les cheveux bleus bonne
nouvelle il ya de la place et les
accepte que je filme dans le salon c'est
très très cool et on va dire au revoir à
ses cheveux nul du coup je pense moi je
me retrouve avec les cheveux blancs ça
va être très très dense commandera faire
des vidéos de youtube her life style
oui ce que j'ai route
[Musique]
tu peux avoir de l'eau pétillante dans
tes cheveux mondiale et le phoque donc
si on fait le bilan je suis en train de
me laver les cheveux avec de la cendre
et les greens on a rarement j'en achète
et la boulangerie en bas du bureau mais
aucun en france et j'ai jamais vu ça
j'ai jamais vu de coiffeur tout court en
fait c'est trop court mais fed avec la
longe et bata pas mal au cou et
d'ailleurs j'avais lu un truc sur sa
débarras les glottes incroyable il ya
des gens qui sont morts chez le coiffeur
parce que justement ça leur nuque appui
énormément jeudi que le truc et du coup
ça fait une bulle dans tes veines qui
monte au cerveau étaient mortes ces
genres un cas sur des milliards mais tu
peux que constater l'échec à cause de ça
à temps mais les onsen je vais je
voulais plus me passer un bon moment
on va maintenant passer à la couleur je
sais pas quelle couleur la faire on va
découvrir ça va être très amusant
[Musique]
enfin papa oui ses cheveux sont très
violents à trèves le rêve devient
réalité
eh ben mon rêve est devenu réalité voilà
la nouvelle coupe celle qui a tout
décidé jamais ce délire je voulais
absolument rentrer dans un salon de
coiffure au japon et dire écoutez moi
bien vous faites ce que vous voulez
crois que mon souhait a été exaucé ça
change énormément
c'est très amusant c'est exactement ce
que je voulais et au pire ça ne l'est
pas dans quelques jours je rase toile
blanche omb les couilles frais et là
j'ai hâte d'un truc c'est de voir la
réaction de mon frère de mon père alors
vers toi alors là objets militaires
américains qui se fit des charges
d'encre violette d'or le et les
beaujolais
il est bon enfant violée dans sa poche
et grâce à un superbe essai de comment
on a rarement s'est élevé à gauche à
bâle là comme ça la vitesse de 60 jours
et bah écoutes je suis content je m'en
fous j'ai au moins ça change ça fait du
bien la couleur les choix de couleurs
jouent du hockey est bon on termine sur
ces mots gentils les hochart c'est rare
c'est rare mais ça fait plaisir
ils sont mignons démange quand même
voilà n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça
vous a plus que d'habitude et puis à
trident une prochaine probablement sur
paris cette fois
et oui le sergent touche à sa fin c'est
hyper triste je suis en train de monter
la vidéo la dernière fois montage cette
chaîne allez à bientôt
au revoir
[Musique]